hey what's up everyone uh i just wanted
to take a second to say a massive thank
you
uh you know everyone sent me amazing
messages some people did some lovely
artwork some people sent me letters
so i just wanted to say thank you uh it
really really means a lot uh i had a
wonderful birthday i was with all my
mates and it was really fun and it was
even better because all of you guys were
there with me
so thank you so much i really appreciate
it and uh
and i'll see you soon hopefully i'll
have some cool stuff to show you some
spider-man stuff someone tried and stuff
soon which will be cool
but i am yeah i really really appreciate
it we'll get back there
and uh i'll speak to you soon also love
bye
what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and as you just saw from tom holland
himself not only does he thank everybody
for wishing him a happy birthday
but he gave us a little tease saying
that hopefully he can show us some
spider-man stuff
pretty soon and it looks like pretty
soon could actually be next week
there is a lot of speculation about the
10th right now with some decent evidence
to back it up
now of course like i mentioned in a
couple of my videos there is the amc
picture stating that the trailer will
indeed drop on june 10th however
the picture hasn't been confirmed real
but it also hasn't been confirmed
fake yet pictures are always tricky
because people can photoshop
very very well and i personally learned
my lesson for the venom 2 trailer
there was a lot of great photoshop work
done for the venom to let there be
carnage trailer stating that it was
coming out a certain day when
in reality it wasn't because it was
photoshopped but that is not what we're
basing
this june 10th trailer release date on
right now
somebody who is very reputable came out
and has stated that
he heard it is indeed going to be on
june 10th
and based off of what we've heard so far
and some things that i've personally
heard
this seems like it could be very
legitimate and could be the day we are
getting the trailer
and i'll explain a few of the reasons
why for starters as i mentioned
this person josh thanos webb
did state that the trailer is dropping
june
10th and he also said that he would take
responsibility if it didn't drop that
day
now josh is a staff writer at the marvel
report which is a marvel
news website twitter instagram etc he
also contributes to athlon sports and
his work has been featured on espn
nbc cbs and more so a pretty reputable
guy
and recently somebody asked him on
twitter about the no way home trailer in
which he replied
trailer drops june 10th and then of
course a lot of people were asking him
how he knew
this information if he was basing it off
of that amc picture
if he was basing it off of some fake
youtube channels that have been created
in which he actually replied and said
i'm definitely not basing it on
a youtube channel this is what i was
told by somebody who told me
about far from home they were absolutely
dead on with far from home
they told me the post credit scenes the
plot twist and
that jk simmons was returning and i
actually remember this i remember going
to the theaters thinking i've heard what
the two post credits scenes are i wonder
if they're real
and they were for far from home so the
credibility seems like
it's there and then of course like i
mentioned in some other videos i have
personally heard that the trailer is
indeed at the theaters and from what
i've been told by people who are in the
industry they only do this when they are
preparing to
actually release it they don't put this
in theaters months and months in advance
they only send trailers to theaters if
it's weeks away from releasing not
months and the trailer has been in
theaters for about a week now maybe a
little bit more
which means june 10th is a very
plausible date
now of course this isn't confirmed i'm
just doing an update on everything that
i've heard so far however this does seem
like it very well could happen
especially since today
tom holland came out and said that
hopefully he can show us some spider-man
no way home stuff
soon and if we take into account that
the loki press junket is on
monday the 7th and loki releases on the
9th we could assume that the trailer
won't come
monday through wednesday however they
could release it that thursday to
promote loki even further and to help
loki promote spider-man no way home as
well hopefully that is the case
hopefully we don't have to wait longer
than june 10th
it does seem like it's happening very
soon especially with these comments from
tom holland but of course we'll have to
wait to find out so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
spider-man no way home
updates and let me know how excited you
are for the spider-man no way home
trailer in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you